She’s known for her dramatic screaming and
crying, and her seemingly dark power to predict
death, the Banshee is seen as a terrifying
female spirit in Irish mythology.
But is she really all that terrifying?
Although some of today’s pop culture has
weaponized the Banshee’s screams and made
them an object of fear, the
first banshees weren’t evil or even dangerous.
She not only predicts your death, but helps
you prepare for it.
This is one monster you might actually want
on your side.
Going back to at least the 8thcentury, Irish
folk tradition depicts the Banshee as the
spirit or ghost of a once living woman.
Banshees appear in two different forms: as
a withered, tiny crone with white hair; or
as a tall, thin, beautiful woman.
The typical banshee has long, flowing hair
and appears dressed in white.
Many times the woman’s spirit becomes a
banshee because of some injustice in her life,
because of bad or “improper” things she
did as a living woman, or was a victim of
violence.
Banshees only appear alone and don’t do
much of anything besides warn the living when
death is coming.
They forewarn the living of death by crying,
screaming, and clapping.
The Old Irish word “Bean sí” directly
translates to “fairy woman,” but etymologists
and folklorists agree that “sí” originally
meant ‘Otherworld’ so the name actually
means ‘Woman of the Otherworld.”
What’s especially unique about the banshee
is that they are only devoted to certain people;
the ancient Gaelic nobility.
Most often, people who have a surname that
begins with an “O,” “Mc,” or “Mac”
. A different banshee belonged to each noble
family and would forewarn deaths, sometimes
appearing to the families’ servants.
She is said to be an ancestor of the family
herself.
In many ways, the banshee is a protector of
the family and its noble land, even a symbol
of the family.
If any part of the ancestral home is still
standing, even if it’s a ruin, she will
appear.
Side note: Although my mom’s ancestors came
from the Munster province in Ireland, which
is full of banshee myths, her family name
is Welsh, so unfortunately, no banshees for
me.
Banshee legends became less common in the
16th and 17thcenturies—possibly because
this is when the British government confiscated
Irish land.
The English families who moved to Ireland
couldn’t have a banshee since they did not
have Irish ancestry—even if they did seize
a noble title.
You can take my title, but you can never take
my banshee.
Many old banshee stories are even classified
by the name of the family they are loyal to.
A famous author, Thomas Crofton Croker, includes
“The Bunworth Banshee” and “The Mac
Carthy Banshee” in his book of Irish folklore.
In both stories, the male heir’s death is
preceded by the wailing and clapping of a
banshee.
So, the banshee’s appearance warns of impending
death.
But why the screaming and moaning?
These expressions of mourning come from Irish
religious and cultural history.
Women have played a crucial role in the Irish
culture of death from the very beginning.
In their mythology, the ancient Celtic battle
goddess Catabodva is also known as Badb.
A variant of her name, just happens to be
the south-eastern Irish name for banshee.
Badb was said to not only influence battles,
but predict the deaths of notable warriors—by
a loud, wailing cry.
She could also shapeshift into a crow, an
ability some banshees have as well.
Another goddess, Brigit, was said to be the
first in all of Ireland to cry and lament
a death, that of her son—yet another connection
between women, death, and crying…or rather
keening.
In the Irish tradition, keening is a rhythmic
wailing and mourning performed by women as
part of the death ritual.
Keening was seen as necessary for the dead
to pass safely into the next world.
Keening women were respected professionals
and performers who guided mourners through
grief with crying and singing.
They were viewed as in-between worlds, the
link between the living world and the Otherworld.
Oh, and did I mention that yet another name
for the banshee is bean chaointe—which in
Gaelic literally means “keening woman.”
Since their actions were seen as necessary,
they were allowed to ignore social customs
while performing.
Keening women might walk barefoot, traveling
not on the roads, but through untamed countryside.
They would appear disheveled, in torn clothes,
and unpinned and uncombed hair.
They were outsiders, and these physical attributes
only served to emphasize their otherworldly
responsibilities.
Despite the supernatural air surrounding keening
women, they served a very practical function.
In times of grief they acted as a catharsis.
Since they were paid professionals, for a
time only wealthy members of society could
afford one, including those old noble families.
So it makes sense that the banshee, who are
in many ways the ghost form of the keening
woman, would only be associated with the upper
class.
Goddesses, keening women, and banshees.
It’s pretty easy to see that women controlled
the voice of death in Ireland.
But I also have another theory, one that I
think explains the accounts of banshees “shrieking.”
Barn owls.
Hear me out.
Barn owls make a truly terrifying screaming
sound.
While they are currently endangered in Ireland,
they used to be widely spread across the country.
Barn owls are nocturnal, hunting (and screeching)
at night.
In the stories that I read, banshees only
appear at night.
The owls horrifying screeching could have
made its way into the Banshee myth.
Maybe someone heard a barn owl’s cry in
the darkness the night before a death in the
family and connected it to the keening Banshee
that also marks death.
The banshee legend not only links Irish people
to their ancestors but emphasizes their belief
in the supernatural.
The Otherworld is important to the creation
of their literary and oral histories.
With elements of mythical ancient goddesses
and real-life keening women, she connects
other worlds as well: fact
and fiction.